a nice polite boy who was always smiling
it's how the mother of 20 year old
terrorist Sudha Sherman described him
holding back her tears while speaking to
Sky News off-camera
Halima Feroz Khan described how she
visited her son last week and said I
spoke to him on Sunday just hours before
he carried out his attack he said he
wanted some of his mother's home cooked
mutton biryani in the final conversation
before he was shot dead by armed police
his mother believes he became more
religious inside prison and he was
watching and listening to things on the
computer which brainwashed him this was
a man under police surveillance because
of his previous terror offenses before
he went to prison in December 2018
sedessa Mann pledged his allegiance to
the Islamic state and declared his own
wish to carry out a terror attack but
growing up he was very smart and wanted
to study biomedical science his mother
told us
a former classmate UPS adesh spoke to
Sky News about their time at high school
he was quiet he had his own little
friend group he stuck to it didn't
really mix with you know many other
people outside the friend group and you
know he was just just seemed like a
pretty normal student don't think that
in school he was involved in that
radicalization I just think that he
lacked a father figure and I think that
he just ended up taking the wrong path
after high school it was at his family's
previous home in North London where
Sudesh stockpiled a combat knife an air
gun and the black flag of Islamic state
he was jailed for over three years after
police found a stash of bomb-making
manuals and other propaganda this was
the teenage life he was living I spent
half an hour speaking to Sudesh Amin's
mother about her son she thinks he was
radicalized by not just the material
online for which he was jailed for but
more so in Belmarsh prison she also said
that he wasn't that faithful before
going inside but when he came out he was
really religious when she first heard
the attack happened on Sunday afternoon
mrs. Khan said she had a feeling her son
was responsible I called him but he
didn't answer she said Sudha Sherman was
a homegrown terrorist his inspired
attack will leave those victim to it and
many witness to it permanently scarred
and now a mother who's lost her 20 year
old son wants to bury him as soon as
possible into mum Rasheed Sky News